Speaker 1: OK, let's talk about what is increasingly
likely going to be the addition of the covid-19
vaccine to school requirements, school vaccination
requirements.
If kids want to go to public schools now,
why am I wording it this way?
Because most states, every state already has
a list of vaccines that are required for students
to attend public school.
And we're going to talk about this in some
detail.
The news that is getting people all worked
up is a report that Dr. Anthony Fauci backs
a covid-19 mandate for U.S. schoolchildren.
Reuters reporting on this, choosing a terrible
picture of Anthony Fauci looking like he's
doing a Nazi salute.
Why this picture was chosen, I don't know.
But the report from Reuters is Dr. Foushee,
top U.S. infectious disease expert, said Sunday
he supports covid vaccine mandates for children
attending schools as the highly contagious
delta variant of the coronavirus continues
to fuel a surge in cases in the nation.
Let's take a look at Dr. Fauci himself saying
yesterday on CNN, remembering, of course,
that children under 12 aren't even eligible
yet.
This is Dr. Dr. Fauci saying what he would
support.
But the vaccine isn't even approved for kids
under 12 yet.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: I believe that mandating vaccines
for children to appear in school is a good
idea.
And remember, Jake, this is not something
new.
We have mandates in many places and schools,
particularly public schools, that if, in fact,
you want a child to come in.
We've done this for decades and decades requiring
polio, measles, mumps, rubella, hepatitis.
So this would not be something new, requiring
vaccinations for children to come to school.
Speaker 1: So this makes sense and it's really
not even remotely controversial.
We're just adding a vaccine.
We would be if this happened, we would just
be adding another vaccine to the list of vaccines
that are required for public school kids.
This is a vaccine that the Fizer vaccine is
now approved by the FDA.
And part of what the right does is create
fear and outrage and uncertainty and doubt
over noncontroversial things.
And this is good.
These are going to be the next battle lines
if you look at the state of Texas.
A bill was introduced in the Texas legislature
to add the covid vaccine to the.
A required school vaccine list, there was
another bill introduced in Texas that goes
directly counter, which would ban adding the
covid vaccine as a required vaccine for schools.
So we're going to see where that goes in Texas.
Texas, of course, has a right wing legislature
and it will probably be the latter rather
than the former.
But it is important to remember that a whole
bunch of states already have these rules.
Let's start with the liberal state of New
York.
When you look at New York, you see very clearly
you need the DTP vaccine.
That's diphtheria, tetanus and pertussis.
If you're going to pre-K, you need four doses
for kindergarten through age, through grade
five.
You need five or four doses or three, depending
on the age of the kids.
For grades six to 12, you need three doses
of the DTP polio vaccine, three doses or four.
Based on the age MMR.
Kids in pre-K need a dose of MMR.
Everybody beyond that needs two doses.
Hep B is on the list.
Varicella chickenpox vaccine now required.
Once you get to grade seven, you need the
meningococcal vaccine, OK?
The point here is New York already has a list
of all of these vaccines.
There just there's no new structure.
It's just add the covid vaccine to that.
Now, if you say, well, sir, New York, very
liberal state, let's look instead at the state
of Alabama.
Alabama, if you look, also has this requirement
and it's kind of strict look at this, the
state of Alabama does not recognize philosophical,
moral or ethical exemption from vaccination.
A medical exemption may be issued by a physician
or an Alabama religious exemption may be obtained.
Some states have even done away with religious
exemptions, but Alabama is already pretty
tight on this.
And then look at the list.
Attendee's of day care and Head Start must
be vaccinated against diphtheria, tetanus,
pertussis, measles, mumps, rubella, influenza,
type B, polio and chicken pox.
We're just talking about adding one more vaccine
and I could go on and give you more requirements
for older kids.
So when we talk about this issue, it's really
important not to let them frame the battle
lines as we're going from nothing to mandating
a vaccine.
No, we're going in theory from mandating six
or seven vaccines to adding a seventh or eighth
that's just been approved by the FDA.
Don't let them set the terms of the debate
and we will ultimately see where this goes.
But remember, it's not even approved for kids
under 12 yet.
There is the next step would be five to 11.
And that's being evaluated right now.
This is going to be a fight, but it's going
to be a necessary one, sadly, because of the
level of ignorance that we have in the United
States.
Let me know what you think will ultimately
happen with these school vaccine mandates.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We are getting dangerously close to one billion
YouTube views when we get there.
We're at nine hundred ninety eight million
when we get to a billion.
YouTube views will be sending out an email
blast with a great membership special.
Get on our newsletter to be notified at David
Pakman dot com.
Remember that the David Pakman show is funded
by viewers like you, by podcast listeners
like you, the podcast, by the way, I don't
know what's going on with the audio podcast,
but we are back to sort of like election 2020
levels with the daily audio podcast downloads.
I don't know what's causing it, but we love
it regardless.
Wherever you listen, wherever you watch, you
can grab a membership and join Pakman Dotcom
and get instant access to the Extra Daily
Show.
It's an additional show every day for our
members.
Sign up at Join Pakman dot com.
You've got a coupon code better.
Twenty one that you can use any time and save
bigly off of that membership